for love and thunder the fourth or solo
flake is scheduled to rock it into
theaters on November 5th 2021
that's more than enough to send fans
racing to mark their calendars but a
major question remained after Marvel
Studios announced love and thunders
release date we know when it's coming to
the big screen but when does it take
place in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Thor is a little flighty when it comes
to keeping track of time after all he's
gonna come back
except you know last time he was gone
for like two years
thanks to Marvel luminary James Gunn who
has not long ago reinstated as the
writer and director of guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 we have an answer in the
comments section of his recent Instagram
post congratulating Avengers end game on
beating avatar at the box office
Gunn fielded a question about Thor love
and thunders place in the MCU in
relation to guardians of the galaxy vol
3 a fan inquired whether love and
thunder will be set before or after the
new guardians flick and gunn gave a
simple one-word answer before Gunn's
response was clear the fourth four comes
before the third guardians but it opens
up a whole can of worms and invites a
lot of speculation the last we saw of
the god of thunder was at the end of
Avengers endgame where he was sporting a
brand new physique and a renewed
interpretation of what it means to be a
superhero handing the kingship of new
Asgard over to Valkyrie and teaming up
with the guardians of the galaxy game
now Marvel filmmakers and screenwriters
basically never do anything without
serious four thoughts it's for this
reason that we can imagine Thor in the
guardians will be together at least at
the start of Thor love and thunder to
pick up where their story left off an
end game exactly like how the events of
Avengers infinity war started mere
moments after the action of four
Ragnarok ended I feel like everything's
gonna work out fine
guns confirmation of win in the MCU Thor
love and thunder takes place
unfortunately doesn't address when
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 will debut
in theaters prior to the Walt Disney
Company booting him from the film after
unsavory past tweets of his surfaced gun
was planning for the next entry in his
franchised premiere sometime in 2020
plans changed after he was fired when
Warner Brothers and DC films poached
Gunn to write and direct the Suicide
Squad a reboot slash sequel to David
Ayres the Suicide Squad as we all know
the house of mouse eventually changed
its tune and tapped Gunn to come back on
board but by then Gunn was committed to
a different movie in a totally different
comic book film franchise Gunn has since
stated that he'll finish the Suicide
Squad before starting production on
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 so that
previously projected 2020 release date
is no longer valid neither of those past
predictions at guardians 3 will be a
base for movie at San Diego comic-con
2019
Marvel dropped a slate of five movies
and five television shows arriving in
2020 and 2021 which studio head Kevin
Feige has said is the complete two phase
four for the time being there's no sign
of guardians on that slate which seems
to mean that the next time we see the
guardians trying to save the galaxy
it'll be in phase 5 probably in 2022 or
2023 there are still some lingering
questions when it comes to Thor love and
thunder and guardians of the galaxy vol
3 but we know two things for sure love
and thunder will bring us Natalie
Portman's Jane Foster as Mighty Thor and
we'll introduce Valkyrie as the first
openly lgbtq+ superhero in the MCU it
may or may not have the guardians of the
galaxy edits but love and thunder is
definitely going to be both lovely and
thunderously fun check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorites
topper coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you